The joe rogan experience.
You ever,
you ever have a friend go crazy on you?
Yeah.
I've had friends that like
legitimately lost their mind.
I can't talk to them anymore.
Like,
like you would talk to them about events
and his version of events were just
like,
so not what actually happened.
You're like,
oh,
this is the person that's
lost their marbles.
Yeah,
yeah.
It happens.
You can temporarily lose your marbles
remanent luncheon or permanently.
Yeah.
But I think that like,
I mean,
yes permanently.
Of course there's like,
no,
I'm not saying through
psychedelics either.
No,
I know what you mean.
Just saying people that just can't keep
it together anymore and for whatever
reason,
whether it's a combination of life,
stress and biological situation,
whatever the fuck they've got going on,
you know,
uniquely in their own brain.
But some people just all of
a sudden not there anymore.
Not keeping it together.
Do they think they're keeping it together?
Sometimes.
Yeah.
I mean there's broad,
broad range,
right?
There's all kinds of,
yeah,
it's,
it sucks man.
People,
the brain is an organ
and it malfunctions and,
and sometimes you go nuts.
And that's,
and you get stigmatized for it,
which really sucks because if you like,
because that just adds to the problem.
Like if you,
you know,
I,
you see somebody in a
cast and you're like,
oh,
what happened to your arm?
And they'll tell you,
oh,
you know,
whatever,
I fell down.
But he,
you,
you talked to someone who's been like
hospitalized for a few weeks and they tell
you I had to go to the hospital.
I had a nervous breakdown.
I went crazy shit,
my pants and through my dog throw window,
you're like,
you know,
you'll,
you'll want,
you want to be compassionate,
but there's some part of you that's like,
oh,
now this is a crazy person.
It's like,
it's just something happened.
The operating system temporarily crashed.
And quite often I think that
could be a very good thing.
I think that having your,
your personality or your ego or crash
can often mean that you were trying to be
somebody that you aren't.
And some people invest so much energy,
so much energy into trying to find me.
Yeah.
They just want to be some thing.
You know they they it,
since there were a kid there,
mother was telling them,
you should be like this,
and then they try to be like
this and they hold up this thing.
They're always working to hold
up this giant tail feather and a,
their arms start shaking and that they
can't hold it up and that's when they
have like anger outbursts are suddenly
like their friends are like you.
You turned into someone
that I've never met.
I don't even know who that is.
It's like,
no,
that is,
you met them.
You met underneath the tail feather,
the seeding.
See anger and disappointment
and sadness that you met.
That thing that they're trying to
avoid by looking up at this mask,
they're holding up to the world,
but that fucking seeding,
see of disappointment,
anger and horror and sadness.
That's where it's at,
man.
You got to go into that thing
and it's for some people,
the only way they can go into that is
by having a full scale nervous breakdown
because then they can have
permission to dive into that,
into that awful vortex of darkness because
underneath that vortex of darkness is
paradise.
Underneath that that's love and happiness
and joy and connection and tranquility
and all that stuff and everyone's thinks
that the way to get to that point is by
avoiding this awful black forest
that surrounds the garden of Eden,
which is inside everybody.
It's inside everybody.
It's there,
it's there and it doesn't matter.
You know you can work out and that
will definitely give you a temporarily
temporary good feeling,
but until you address the internal
structures that you haven't acknowledged,
you're always going to go back to that
place where you find yourself morose and
depressed and angry
and you don't know why.
You always go back to that place until
you sit with the sadness inside of you.
You have to do that.
What you're describing is
coming out of the closet.
Yeah.
For a lot of people that is what it is.
Man,
it's coming out of the closet and there's
a lot of closets and there's not just
the gay closet,
right?
There's all kinds of closet.
There's the artists closet.
Some people are fucking accountants.
They're wearing suits and their ties on
tight and they're fucking like organized
and disciplined.
But inside they're probably painters.
They probably want to fucking paint.
They want to paint Dayglo
mountains down at the beach.
That's what they really are.
But their daddy or their mommy wanted
them to be a good little businessman.
So they became this thing that's
the opposite of what they are.
This is the verse in the Bhagavad Gita.
God,
forgive me cause I've quoted
it way too many times,
but it's,
it's better to be an honest street
sweeper than a dishonest king.
It's better to be a happy guy brushing
fucking leafs up the street than it is to
be some zillionaire who inside
is dying or numb or miserable.
Mostly Numb,
numbs the word.
Most people are just,
as long as these people
can quantify on paper,
I still have a x million dollar home.
My car is still cost x thousand
dollars this suit is an ex suit.
I am still ahead.
I am not going to
abandon all these things.
As long as they don't see
through the bullshit of the game,
they think they're winning.
They have to fall.
Yeah.
It's almost like you have to fall to,
to really,
that's what you got to appreciate those
moments when it all falls apart on you
because that means you've got
an opportunity to try it again.
This is,
let's take a new fresh perspective.
This is the cool thing that
at this retreat I went to
this Guy Jack Cornfield's
out,
which I really loved and
a great name by the way.
Yeah.
With a k not a c,
Jack Kornfield,
mortal Kombat k Jack Cornfield.
But he,
uh,
he's really cool man.
But he was cool with the kid.
He's like the cigarettes.
No,
this guy was awesome.
And he was one of the things he talked
about his in some religious tradition,
how they like hold the scriptures a rabbi.
Like,
how does students hold the
scriptures over their heart?
And,
uh,
when they were memorizing
them and they would say,
why do we do this?
And he said,
so that when your heartbreaks,
they'll fall in.
And it's a beautiful idea,
which is that heartbreak is
actually your ego cracking.
And the moment that cracks,
you're in the experience of truth.
And when you're in the experience of,
that's when you can
really become who you are.
But,
but to get to who you are,
it's like when you know,
on a bone heals the wrong way.
Like that's what a lot of
people's entire personality is.
It's like a bone that grew the
wrong way and that needs a fucking
check,
a snap or a crack,
you know,
and we,
you get that through slot,
you need that,
that initial fucking thing.
And it's a beautiful analogy and it hurts.
It hurts.
But we're paying avoiding creatures.
So we think that,
so we're always running
away from this pain.
But the problem is as we're
running away from pain,
we're still exactly in pain.
It's basically like being on
fire and running away from water.
You're just running away
from the water because you,
for some,
I don't know.
That's a stupid analogy
actually for great.
Up until that,
yeah,
you had a lot of great points.
It's true.
You know there's the monster in
the dark and the faster you run,
the more likely you are to
run into something that's
actually going to hurt you
as opposed to turning around and saying,
oh fuck.
There is no monster,
no monster.
You know?
But you're never get to know that
until you stop and turn around.
In some cases people don't have the
discipline or the the assistance or the
balls to stop and turn around so they
have to trip over something and then
there's like,
oh look,
that's the classic story.
Classic story of someone hiding a secret
and going completely out of control
because of the pressure of hiding that.
Like that's the Ted Haggerty who's the
secretly gay guy who's preaching against
gay people.
Ted Haggard and Colorado.
I was snorting meth off his gay lovers.
Yeah.
We was just going so far the other way.
He just so off the rails crazy himself.
He's being himself.
He was a guy who likes
to snort math off of Cox.
I still a little math and he likes to,
well,
there's a few Cox,
but I would say he wasn't being himself.
What I would say is that his,
his behavior was so extreme because he
was seeking balance between that and the
other bull shit in his life.
Whereas if he weren't living that,
he'd be right in the middle,
right?
Yeah.
Well to give,
but to get to the middle,
you know the way to get to the middle
weirdly is whatever the behavior is that
you're doing that you're so horrified
about and terrified of sometimes that
they're really weird ideas.
This is like something
that I liked that Ron says,
which is like,
Duh.
If you don't feel like meditating,
don't meditate.
Don't force it.
Don't impose this on yourself.
Keep doing the thing you're doing
that's upsetting you so much.
Have the balls to keep doing the
fucking thing that you're doing.
Keep doing it.
If society is going to tell you,
don't be like this,
stop being like this.
You have to change.
That's what your parents always say.
The idea is like no,
sink into what you are right now.
Just be that thing.
Stop resisting exactly where
you are right now is perfect.
And that's a hard truth to grasp
because you think right away,
you think.
Yeah.
What about fucking Jeffrey Dahmer?
Is he perfect?
Well,
what about the leopard?
When you're seeing a leopard
rip apart a creature?
Is that thing per,
is that a perfect moment?
It fucks them.
And then him.
But
you know what?
Ducks do.
Docs or necrophilia acts.
Are they fucking evil creatures?
We think they are.
They are made that Phil Robertson Guy,
very famous person,
cause he invented a call for them.
And now poor gay people have to hear
that a man's anus is not as good as a
woman's vagina.
Can you imagine if you made the choice
for a man's anus and you hear this
fucking big bearded Fashionista with his,
uh,
Cammo on a Bandana is
absolutely fascinating.
So weird.
I never thought of that.
Big bearded Christian
Bible Slang Fashionista.
And uh,
he tells you that your
choice was incorrect.
That in fact,
the woman's vagina is the better choice.
The man's anus.
I mean,
come on guys,
but how can you say that if
you haven't experienced it?
Maybe.
Yeah.
I think he has a,
again,
the balance theory,
I think he's so outspoken on that issue.
Like most of these homophobes are because
they're home jerking off to gay porn,
but you know,
otherwise you just don't give a shit.
It just doesn't actually matter.
Right.
It doesn't come up in a GQ
interview duffing thing.
Right.
It's like Duh.
Already.
If you really care if people are gay,
Duh,
uh,
you really care.
The two guys love each other and
that you are you against love.
Yeah.
Love if it's a man and a woman.
Like,
what the fuck man.
Really?
Yeah,
it's done.
If you're talking about
men's anuses in Gq,
so you,
maybe you've got some
issues to think about.
Shouldn't we just be talking about ducks,
ducks,
any this season that your whole,
she knows the ducks.
You shoot ducks all the time.
Right?
That's your thing.
Let's just talk about murdering ducks.
Yeah.
Why you got to talk about men's asshole
ragging this in the blood stacks.
Well,
the only way you can live that
fake life as if it's fake.
The actual,
you know,
this,
this I,
this puritanical ideal
that they've held up.
It's not natural and they haven't been
really living in any way they've been
pretending to be living.
It would be freaks in this
sort of a rebound sort of
a way to balance everything
out.
And I think that ultimately that's being
exposed over and over and over and over
again to the point where it's not
going to be a viable option anymore.
Like powdered wigs aren't a viable option
and you can't wear a fucking powdered
wig.
You know,
and you can't pretend you're this,
you know,
Rick Santorum,
guy that you know,
just as a good man who believes in
the Bible and doesn't want to see gays
getting married,
doesn't want to ruin the institution of
marriage with homosexual activity that's
been shunned upon in the Bible quote.
And you're like,
oh,
fucking crime.
Any,
what's going on?
Really?
What's going on behind
the scenes with you cat?
What is in your head then I keep waiting
for it to get to that point where
anybody who's got a big problem with
homosexuality is by default admitting to
their own homosexual life.
But I've been waiting 30
years for America to go,
come on.
This is too silly to be real.
Ronald Reagan,
are you kidding?
That guy was such a joke.
But you know,
he's St Ronald and the
seeds planted 30 years ago.
Well,
even then,
there was voted for him.
But you,
do you remember the criticism though?
It was pretty open.
There was a lot of people
that didn't like him.
I remember when he was an odd,
not enough that he didn't win 49
out of 50 states in Israel election.
Oh,
well listen man,
I'm not saying that.
You know,
he didn't dominate the
vast majority of the,
you know,
I mean,
there was a lot of idiots back then,
but the difference between the way people
look at them now and the way people
looked at him then now it's almost all
glowing when people talk about ranking,
and I hardly ever hear any criticism.
Yeah.
You don't hear about Iran Contra Nicaragua
and El Salvador and all of the crazy
all over north,
all over and all that craziness.
And you know,
yeah.
But my point,
my point is that this idea of it suddenly
we're going to wake up and realize how
ridiculous it is.
And it's a,
Rick Santorum is too ridiculous to be
real fucking what's her name's Sarah
Pailin.
Mm.
You know,
I am amazed that how flexible
the reality muscle seems to be,
that people are willing to accept this
stuff that Frank Zappa was laughing about
40 years ago.
Well,
I wonder if they are accepting it though.
I wonder.
I think that you watch these shows
enough and it creates the illusion of
acceptance.
But then if you,
if w anywhere on the internet or any,
you just see this constant
rebellion against that kind of,
um,
uh,
square,
mainstream,
homophobic,
angry personality and,
but you watch Fox News and yeah,
you watch Fox News.
Are you watching anything on TV?
And it's an illusion.
You know,
you watch the commercials,
everything's is big illusion.
You watch the commercials and it's like
people go in and buy a car and make it
seems normal.
It seems totally normal that people are
going in to get deeply in debt to the
banks.
That all seems incredibly normal.
But then more and more on
the Internet you see like,
uh,
people rebelling against this
and showing how the bankers,
like the whole system is this fucked up
thing and emerging things like bitcoin.
What's your like slowly moving
the energy away from it?
I don't know.
I didn't know what you mean.
I don't think it's going
to be a sudden thing.
I think it's going to be more like a,
just a gradual shift is
people just stop watching TV.
That's,
that's going to happen.
People are just gonna you know,
I drive down the street
billboards for fucking,
um,
like amazon.com shows,
you know,
like billboards for shows that aren't
really controlled by these big networks.
Netflix,
yeah,
yeah.
But it's an Amazon,
just another big network.
I mean,
you know,
it doesn't matter if it's a network or
it's an international conglomerate or
whatever it is.
It's big money.
It is,
but you're right,
but that's just the bill.
Yeah.
The reality is it's that,
but yeah,
but it's not,
it's not right because the
media is a very different thing.
The media where you
talking about television,
you're talking about a very hard
thing to get into the medium.
When you're talking about an inner,
you're talking about an
incredibly easy thing to get into.
Literally open to almost anyone
with an internet connection.
You can make a youtube video
doesn't cost you a god damn dime.
Yeah.
You have a laptop that has a camera on it.
You talk into it,
you make a youtube video that,
yeah,
that's a big change.
That's not just a big change.
That might be the biggest
change in human history.
It might be the biggest change
since a monkey ate a mushroom.
Right.
Certainly since the printing,
the printing press was a major for sure.
Giant,
you know,
and,
and similar in the sense that it,
it took the power of communication away
from very few and gave it to a lot more
right in,
that's sort of one of the more fascinating
things about this is that there is,
you know,
even if Amazon does,
but something online,
it's no better than I
Justine who has like,
you know,
45 fucking billion followers and she,
every video she put there,
there's people like that that just
became famous for the Internet.
Yeah.
Jenna marbles is another one,
right?
She,
she's got like millions and
millions and millions of hits.
Okay.
Yeah.
Here's what it is.
Cause I,
I'd just been reading
Sheldrake's new book,
um,
science set free and he talks about
morphic resonance or something.
And I know you have some,
I think you've,
you're skeptical about Sheldrake,
but,
uh,
I,
it's like when you've just have TV,
TV's a tuning fork and when there was no
internet and it was just TV and it was
a depiction of here's
what a family looks like,
here's what people tend to,
it's a corporation saying here's
what people do when they're healthy.
And that creates a tuning fork effect,
which is like,
if you're watching it enough,
you're going to either resonate
with or are in and feel like,
yes,
I'm doing great.
I have a wife and a house and a
car and a job and that's great.
I'm in tune with what
everyone else is doing.
But that's an illusion.
That's never been what
everyone else is doing.
It's just what massive
conglomerates are sending out there.
Um,
either in the form of hypnotic content
that keeps you glued to your seat.
As you watch corporations try
to get you in debt to buy cars.
You know,
it's,
it's generally,
it's just,
it's,
uh,
the whole thing is just,
tuning all of society,
uh,
in a way that society maybe
isn't meant to be tuned at all.
And so with the Internet now you have
all these different smaller tuning forks.
You know,
your podcast is a tuning fork.
People tune in to the stuff that you
talk about and the different people that
you bring on the podcast,
send out information that causes a
new kind of tuning to start happening.
So that's why when you
watch like Huckabee,
you'd really feel like you're like
listening to somebody sing off key cause
you're not resonating,
you're not resonating.
You've been tuned into
a whole different thing,
which is what the internets,
I think one of the major
things the Internet has done,
you know,
you get these communities read it,
you can get tuned into the
reddit frequency quite easily,
where suddenly it all
just starts making sense.
And that is why the,
you know,
the duck dynasty guy or any
of these Weirdos who are,
um,
are just ultimately just angry people.
That's why they seem so fucking crazy.
Or they play angry people on TV.
All right.
Cause I think a lot of
these people aren't even,
you know,
like in politics dynasty guy,
the duck dynasty guy has been giving
speeches like that for years that these
biblical retreats and stuff,
he's been doing that for this video.
Oh,
this is real schtick.
He's not fire and brimstone.
God fearing Christian man who was living
on the wrong side of the law and Jesus
at one point in time and then turn it all
around and wants to let everybody know
about the evils of sin.
He's an old dummy.
That's what he is.
He's an old dominion.
Loved their scientific name for him.
He's an old dummy to
probably just one time,
sucked a dick and liked it way too much.
If someone sucked his dick
and it's his favorite moment.
Ah,
it looks back on his childhood
and he's turned it into,
you know,
career.
I bet he was hunting
ducks when it happened.
I bet he was hiring that duck blind.
They're all liquored up and
moonshine and cozy hunting ducks.
I bet.
Right when he came into like
some guy's mouth years ago,
out in the out in the swamps,
he saw what they call it a duck blind.
Yeah.
I'm fine to pleasure and
shame mixed inside of me.
He's like,
I'm just going to kill.us from now
on and never think about this dog.
She didn't see shit.
Your Mother didn't see shit.
Your father didn't see shit.
Nobody son Shit good too.
Can you imagine if that's really what
it was all it was just a duck psalm.
Get his dick sucked by
a guy and he's like,
fuck that.
It didn't happen.
Need to kill ducks.
I think that's something
like that happened,
man.
It's something like that happen,
but you know man,
like what you do with with,
you know,
sex at dawn creates a resonance
where it's like it's a,
it's a shame reliever.
It's a shame.
Reduce her man.
Because your book,
I think it has been,
it's such a compassionate book for
people who are stuck in monogamous
relationships and feel guilty about the
fact that they are attracted to other
people and that's like that guilt used
to be a normal guilt that was actually
considered like,
oh,
something must be going
wrong with your relationship.
If you're thinking about fucking
other people and your book,
it show us like,
no,
actually that's just nature
happening through you.
You don't have to feel guilty about it
or like something's off balance in you.
It's just completely normal.
It doesn't mean you have to
go and fuck other people,
but at least now you don't have to feel
like I must not love or anymore or she
must not love me anymore.
What's that have to do with fucking docs,
country music songs.
That's the glue,
the glue that connects these two fucking
ducks and the sadness you have for not
wanting to be monogamy.
That's the glue that
keeps it all together.
It's the glue that holds the,
that's why you need listen
to Phil Robertson and that,
that God damn communist
and he that puts them on,
is that what it's on?
[inaudible] hilarious.
It's on a and e and I used to be like
fucking masterpiece theater and shit.
Yeah.
These to have like,
you know,
arts and entertainment,
interesting,
fascinating program.
And it's stimulated the mind.
I don't sell cars,
thou,
it's fucking,
you know,
people let found a storage box,
what's in the storage box.
But there's a lot of good stuff in there.
I bet there's nothing in
there more after the break.
Yeah.
I wonder what,
how much you take for that $500.
I can't give you five.
I can give you story.
I got to get at least four.
I don't know.
Cut to commercial narrative are,
I'll tell you,
this is my last offer and I'll be
in a serious cut to commercial.
Wow.
Wonder what his last offer is going to be.
Ah,
he got them down to three.
I wish I could,
yeah.